thank you
it's the police there's no one here with
guns he's hallucinating he's having
alcohol withdrawals I don't want this
problems here I just moved into this
house like like I don't need this okay
my landlord lives across the street he's
having drunk hallucinations he he called
you guys for no reason do you want us to
talk to him he's he's seeing stuff
that's not there do you do you think he
needs an ambulance every time I take
this to the hospital all they do is
release him
that's all that's all they do they're
here now ma'am it's fine
what's I mean is he just drunk or is he
alcohol withdrawal hallucinations he was
a severe alcoholic he hasn't had alcohol
in four days he's going through
hallucinations from withdrawal he's not
being violent or anything no he's just
seeing
voices in his head okay
valuation you're more than welcome to do
you think it's necessary do you think he
just needs to I think he needs help yes
to work he's done called 911 well if you
want us to come in and talk to them we'd
be more than happy
where's he at he's in his bedroom
what's his name
Earl
it's the police
you called us my man
you need some help
we're good
huh
you need an ambulance another 28. Second
Street
48.
sweating
248 North 8th Street
24.
[Music]
what's happening my man
you know where you're at right now man
home where's home
[Applause]
[Music]
do you know where home is
North 25th stay away
we're gonna stay here but you're not on
North 25th
you know who the president is
[Music]
you know here it is bud
success
yeah let's start with this you know what
uh your name is can you give us that
around 20.
[Music]
Earl what's your last name
what's going on with you my man
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we're gonna have an ambulance come
check you out but man make sure you're
okay
looks like you're having some kind of
problems
very peaceful music
[Music]
hey everyone who's that female out there
yeah
who is she to you
[Music]
or she's worried about you man she said
she's been struggling a little bit
what's up he's been trying to get off
the sauce a little bit
and that shit ain't easy cold turkey man
that's messing me up real bad right now
[Music]
let's get his name from her
Earl
[Music]
ier
how long you been feeling like this my
man
foreign
[Music]
do you remember why you called the
police
[Music]
oh my goodness
nice Jordan
what's up bud
now he's hard yeah man we get you some
water
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
feeling a little better yeah
yeah
you're sweating up a storm my man
all right
[Music]
oh there's your water
oh
maybe just set it down I guess is that
he wanted water
foreign
[Music]
um
relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
changes
[Music]
pictures
how is that right no those are all here
foreign
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
oh
oh oh
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
what's up
oh oh oh
my God everybody
[Music]
all right
please
[Music]
thank you
This Is Earl
[Music]
I haven't been able to get much out of
them
it's day three
all right he was up on his bed and he
just rolled off onto the floor after
he's been slowly stripping off of his
clothes
[Music]
what was his last name
was born in March but we don't have
injectors Earl
what's your birthday man
okay
[Music]
this is about all we've been able to
give
Earl sit up
[Music]
sit up
you know what I am not playing
come on or a little oh yeah
sit up
sit up now
I am not playing with you tonight
sit up
what is your birthday
yes
or 20 seconds March 22nd what year
Earl do you want to go to the hospital
ma'am we need then we need to get up all
right we ain't carrying you so let's
let's get up on your feet
because I am seriously not in the mood
for this dumb shit you can walk come on
let's stand up
I know you can do it I've seen you do it
I swear no stand up use your legs
tomorrow get your smell Bud let's take
Dakota myself
[Music]
you're not a dead weight
maybe we are
all right
now
get up
or you can stay here
if you want to go to the hospital man
you got to help us out a little bit
Earl are you gonna go are you gonna stay
blood
You're Gonna Go you need to get up and
walk
what's up
what's up buddy
you want to go all right get up come on
you got to use your legs man you can't
just go dead weight on it
because you need to help get up and go
to the hospital we'll give you the help
Bud you need the help
we're hospitaling we go to St John's
come on let's go help me out let's go
come on help yourself all right one two
there you go there you go there you go
come on buddy keep it moving all right
we're moving we're moving let's keep
going One Foot In Front of Me come on
we'll hold you up but you got to walk
forward come on buddy
music
yeah
man you gotta you gotta help us out a
little bit
we ain't never gonna get out of this
house
all right
guys you gotta get up and go you need
the help
are you freaking kidding me man I know
you can walk
all you gotta do is get outside there
cots outside
come on you can walk get up
we're gonna leave you here buddy we
don't want to do that but
we can't carry all the way
girl get up you call them you need to go
go to the hospital the ambulance is
outside waiting for you get up all you
gotta do is walk out that front door
hey it's right outside waiting for it
girl get up
we're right outside the door get up
yeah we all he has to do is walk out
there
come on you called you wanted to help
come on get up
all right we got another 10 feet
10 feet my man
come on
let's go on this uh we got 10 feet we're
gonna go right to the door and you can
lay down and you can fall face first on
that car
yeah
we're doing one swing though We're not
gonna take anymore all right we got you
ready we're doing it
right here couch right there
right there
keep going buddy
all you gotta do is go right there
watch your Noggin I know it's cold I
know it's cold
keep going keep going negative come on
buddy
now get up on there man
let's go and get up on there bud I can't
get you there if you don't get on the
cot
get the bed on wheels
get up there all right we're spinning
them around all right
stand up stand up
oh
all right Earl this is getting a little
silly man
there we go
foreign
[Applause]
thanks
oh I'm gonna wait till he gets in there
yeah he gets in there he'll find his way
to dead weight off of that thing
yeah I got a whole mess of it why didn't
you put on your clothes
come on McFly I'm Gonna Fly hello